the Pentagon is declassifying video and
photos of the raid that killed Isis
leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi they could
be released by tomorrow meanwhile
president Trump is praising the dog that
cornered al Baghdady at his hideout in
northwestern Syria David Martin is at
the Pentagon David good morning so what
more do we know today about this mission
we now know that after further testing
to confirm his identity al Baghdadi's
remains have been buried at sea so al
Baghdadi is dead but Isis is not in the
mission now is to use the intelligence
collected in Saturday's raids to go
after the rest of his network his death
marks a devastating blow for the
remnants of Isis the Delta force that
led the rage spent about two hours at al
Baghdadi's compound they executed the
raid in all of its facets brilliantly
the u.s. came away with cell phones and
laptops which potentially can point the
Delta Force in the direction of other
Isis hideouts how much material did you
take away there was material taken away
I don't want to characterize exactly
what or how much yet until it gets
exploited properly this is the Delta dog
which chased al macdaddy down a dead-end
tunnel where he set off his suicide vest
killing himself and three children with
him five other people were killed in the
compound by the Delta Force two were
captured there were two adult males
taken off the objective alive and
they're in our custody those
lieutenant's may be able to shed light
on what happened to Kayla Mueller a
young aid worker al Baghdady had
captured him brutalized the raid was
named after Kayla and her parents spoke
on Monday until we have her home we
truly don't know what happened to her
resolute aunts have been captured and
who else would know what happened to
Kayla
but these people close to him we're also
learning more about how the u.s. found
out back daddy
general [ __ ] Abdi of the Syrian
democratic forces said the Kurds had an
informant within al Baghdadi's inner
circle
the informant reportedly tracked down
Baghdady for five months and provided a
floor plan of his hide
including the number of guards and
location of tunnels President Trump says
al-baghdadi was the only Isis leader he
cared about getting because his was the
only name people recognize but the day
after the raid a CIA drone strike killed
the chief spokesman for Isis a man many
had thought would be a possible
successor to al Baghdadi David thank you